it's not anything about who you are as a
person but it's what men value so you
can't so so you can't go up to guys and
say don't value this because it's what
they want so that's like me selling a
car and going up to the people that want
to buy a car and say like this car and
they say no I don't want to buy that car
because it's got too many miles and
you're saying well you should light cars
with high miles
honestly we're talking about completely
different stuff so women can't get no
title like that because when she said
that nobody's gonna know you have about
30 Men You're gonna be as Loose as held
men know and like the thing is you know
and at the end of the day if a woman
sleeps with loads of men she's she's a
if a man man speaks of loads of
women is a stud
show from the